بلاد الرافدين امام ازمه شح المياه الذي
يعتبره الكثيرون كارثه بايتنا تهدد لقمه
عيش مئات الالاف من العراقيين الذين تعتمد
معيشتهم على المياه عن طريق صيد الاسماك
او تربيه الجواميس او الزراعه وهو الامر
الذي تراجع خلال السنوات الماضيه بدرجه
كبيره
كما فقد صياد الاسماك اكثر من 97% من
المخزون السمكه لم يتبقى سوى الاسماك
البسيطه الاسماك الملحيه التي لا يتجاوز
سعر الكيلو غرام منها بالف دينار عراقي
للاسف الشديد ذوي القصب والبردي
وتاثر التنوع الاحيائي هذا التنوع الحياه
الهائل الذي دخلت من اجله الاهوار
العراقيه في تموز من عام 20 16 الى لائحه
التراث العالمي للاسف الشديد نحن نقول ان
نتدخلنا لائحه التراث العالمي ودخل على
مواقع رامز
الوسطى لكن همم
تاثرت بها كثيره